is there a tattoo that is so cliched if
someone asks for it you say don't do
that
like i i stopped doing names
a while ago of partners yes yeah
because that's definitely the number one
cover-up and
so many times when i was doing it in my
head i'm like
it's not gonna this isn't gonna work out
i just
they would know the person after like a
week and finally i just
said no i can't can't do it anymore you
know i have met
hardcore fans many times who have
there's a little
uh sort of cartoon conan insignia and
they have that
i don't think it's ever been a guy it's
always a woman but they have it on their
ankle
or they have it somewhere on their arm
uh they have the little conan face
and i don't know how i feel about it
because
i mean i i know i should be flattered
and i'm glad that they're a fan
but nothing is less uh attractive to me
than my
face on another woman's body i don't
know
i don't know how to i don't know why
that is but i just i feel
sad for everyone i feel sad for them
myself everybody
i don't know so so you're a tattoo
artist
and um i was how long does it take to do
your average tattoo forget
a flaming eagle clutching a nuclear
submarine
and saying something in russian um whoa
yeah flaming eagle clutching a nuclear
submarine
and then uh and then quoting from mao's
red book but
in russian uh that is the tattoo that i
would get across my back someday
when it's time but my question for you
is it must take
a couple of hours to do a tattoo do you
talk to the people while you're giving
them the tattoo
yes i love it that's probably my
favorite part people
get you know people definitely open up
to you while you're tattooing them
it's such a vulnerable time and i love
hearing dating stories
and just getting deep do you ever get
anybody that you're five minutes in
you're like oh no this is a mistake this
is two hours of a conversation that i
don't have the capacity for
well there was a tattoo that i did on
this
gentleman who came in and he got a name
and it had a character next to it and he
initially disguised it as
a a tattoo for a cousin i believe and
when i was doing the finishing touches
on it
he revealed to me that it was actually
for someone that he was in love with
and which breaks your rule this breaks
your cardinal rule yes
and then he lifted his sleeve up and had
numerous other names no women's names on
him
oh no what what this this is a true
crime
story you are going to be i was
horrified
yeah so uh so you were done with the
tattoo at that point
was he back a week later trying to get
another name put on there
and was it yours yeah
could you put christina on here it's a
different christina
she's a tattoo artist from bamario
california
i'm going to pitch you an idea and i
want you to think about it christina and
matt you're an expert in this space i am
not i
i've dabbled and stumbled into the
podcast space
what about making it a podcast what if
and i'm not even kidding
what if christina had uh a podcast
so you recorded your conversations while
you're tattooing people
and then we edited it down tightened it
up
you'd get these fascinating stories from
people
and then people could go online and they
could look at the tattoo that's a
brilliant idea this reminds me of the
there's a podcast where people
do therapy but the patients are
anonymous and so the tattoo client could
be anonymous
yes you can get all the juice out of
them no no i'm i'm
listen i'm a guy who comes up with ideas
uh that's good
it has sustained me since uh well my
whole life really
um but uh i think that should be a
podcast i would
listen to yes i know someone's gonna
damn it someone's gonna rip this off
this is gonna air it's gonna go out
there i always say air what is the
proper term gurley this is going to drop
i guess drop or yeah i don't know that
there is a good term
let's come up with one now let's come up
with one you know
this is gonna this is gonna hit the
caramel let's call it hit the caramel
this is gonna this is gonna hit the
caramel that means the podcast has been
released
um in my official terminology um this
episode's going to hit the caramel and
someone's going to rip this off
immediately because it's such a good
idea
trademark yeah if it hasn't been done a
hundred times already because there's a
million podcasts but if it hasn't we
should get on this
yeah it's a good idea it has i talked to
one of my good friends jess about it
actually because we were like dang like
people tell us the craziest stories
while they're getting tattooed
it's really entertaining i think this
could be uh
i think this could be a podcast and i've
now can you verbally agree to do this
with me uh christina right now uh
and just trust me on any kind of
financial arrangement that might ensue
yes what no wow
christina no hey she technically said
yes
it doesn't matter how she said it tattoo
therapy here we come
yeah there's a there's a pun with ink
that's really obvious that we're not
thinking of right now uh and um but
we'll come up with it or sleeve or
something like that
heart on the sleeve that's good pretty
good
okay so we've got the title her on the
sleeve i've got a verbal agreement from
christina this will be a podcast that we
are going to
produce you've also made it very clear
and this will be played
in court because you are going to sue me
um
that you're fine with whatever
arrangement financial that i decide to
make
uh now at first you'll notice no money's
coming in and then later about two years
later you'll notice really no money's
coming in
trust me and you'll notice on the street
a lot of people are saying i love your
podcast christina i listen to it all the
time and so do all my friends and i
can't believe
amex is doing ads on it and you'll still
see no money
uh and then you'll notice that i'm
walking around in a yachting cap
you're losing money on this you start to
lose
oh money and i start to wear solid gold
nike basketball sneakers
that are very uncomfortable